เฮ
[Música]
Olá, minhas amigas, meus amigos. Sejam
muito bem-vindos mais uma live.
É um prazer estar aqui com vocês.
Eh, boa noite, Ana Paulo Rodrigues,
Márcio Souza,
Simo,
Marinete,
Caridade, Alice Vogel. Vocês estão me
ouvindo bem?
Me respondam se tá ouvindo bem.
Boa noite,
Anelos
Reof, acho que é isso.
Estão me ouvindo bem? Beleza, vamos
começar então respondendo as perguntas
de vocês.
Deixa eu voltar a apresentar aqui. Deixa
eu colocar a tela
sozinha aqui.
Como tratar o basto crescido
sem diagnóstico de parecer conclusivo?
Então, a gente tem que aprofundar
primeiro a investigação através de uma
avaliação mais detalhada para entender
por que tá crescido. se inclui teste de
sensibilidade alimentar, investigação de
inflamação
sistêmica, ver se essa pessoa não teve,
por exemplo,
uma parasitosa que justifica esse basto
aumentado, se não tem uma anemia
congênita,
vê se não tem uma antibiose intestinal,
se não tem uma infecção
silenciosa,
muitas vezes se basta aumentada é uma
reação inflamatória crônica.
desencadeado por alimentos que são
alimentos inflamatórios. Podem ser, por
exemplo,
situações específicas aí de pessoas que
têm sensibilidade ao glútpermeabilidade
intestinal com ativação desnecessária do
sistema imunológico.
Pode ser uma parasitose
também, pode ser também uma pessoa que
tá enem falsiforme e não sabe.
Então isso é muito importante fazer essa
investigação completa. Se não for
identificado nem uma anemia falsiforme e
nem uma parasitose, aí você pode estar
introduzindo uma dieta antiinflamatória,
suplementação, né, de complexo B,
vitamina D
e fazer um acompanhamento regular contra
trassonografia
para monitorar a evolução.
Existe, por exemplo,
a questão de você testar para
leximaniose, que pode aumentar o basso,
testar para bar, para citomal vírus,
para
me fugir o nome. Me ajuda aí, Dra. Ana
Paula.
Qual que é mesmo o nome
daquela parasitose do amarelão? Me fugiu
o nome agora.
esperar ela responder aqui
lá antes dela responder aqui, ó. Quem se
interessar em participar do CIS, simpose
de saúde integrativa aqui em São Paulo
nos dias 13 e 14 e 15 de março para
profissionais de todas as áreas de saúde
com esse ano foco em neurocognição, tá?
Convite a todos vocês aí.
Ancilostoma.
Sim, ansilostomiase, sim, mas eu não
tava pensando em silostoma, tava
pensando
naquele outro.
Tem um card de desconto de 20%. Onde é
que tá esse card?
Ah, tá. Eh, se você se inscrever no
congresso, você vai, na hora de você
fechar lá a compra, você pode colocar
esse código Alin 20 aí, tá?
Beleza, pessoal. Vamos continuar aqui
então nas perguntas.
Qual é a dose?
Ué, que que tá acontecendo aqui? Pera
aí.
Ah, tá. Pera aí. Me dá só um minutinho
aqui.
Qual que é a dose do EPA e do DH? é
utilizada para quem tem transtorno
afetivo bipolar tipo dois. Para esse
transtorno é possível substituir o
carbonato de lítio pelo rotato de lítio
e adicionar este ao primeiro. O lítio
tem um papel importante no controle da
ansiedade, tem ação na dopamina. Boas
perguntas. Boas perguntas.
Então, para bipolaridade
existe literatura recente recomendando o
uso do EPA e DHA na proporção de um para
dois, tá? Então, entre 1 a 2 g diários
com predominância do DHA.
OK?
Ah, desculpa, não é bem isso não. Na
verdade, a proporção do E para pro DHA é
de dois para um ou três para um. você
toma 2 g da combinação, mas tem mais EPA
do que DHA, tá? O EPA nesse caso ele foi
particularmente importante porque
estudos mostraram a eficácia
especialmente na depressão bipolar
quando representa pelo menos 60% do
total. Então tem que ter maisodo do que
DHA, tá?
Alguns estudos com doses mais altas
foram feitos com até 10 g por dia, teve
bons resultados também e reduziu de
forma significativa as recaídas
depressivas.
Como é que funciona? Eles funcionam
através de modulação
da inflamação, né? São
anti-inflamatórios
que melhoram principalmente sintomas
depressivos e não os maníacos.
O orotato de lítio a gente usa mais como
prevenção do que com tratamento.
Ele tem uma ótima biodisponibilidade,
ele tem menos efeitos colaterais, muito
menos comparado com carbonato.
Agora, substituir o carbonato de lítio
para uma pessoa que tem bipolaridade
pelo orotato é bem complicado,
porque o orotato ele é vendido como
suplemento alimentar
e o carbonato é vendido como remédio. E
sinceramente eu nunca
fiz essa troca dessa forma. Teoricamente
você poderia estar utilizando de lío,
sim, só que numa dose mais alta, não 10
mg por dia, teria que tá utilizando pelo
menos 50 mg por dia, mas isso com o
acompanhamento de um psiquiatra
integrativo, OK?
Então, a gente sabe que o lío, na forma
de rotato tem múltiplas ações
neuromoduladoras, auxilia no controle da
ansiedade, estabiliza
neurotransmissores, reduz atividade
excessiva
cerebral,
ação sobre a dopamina é inibitória, não
estimulatória,
o que pode ser uma limitação em
pacientes que têm muita alergia, né? né?
Ou seja, não tem vontade de fazer nada,
falta de motivação. Por isso, muitas
vezes, é importante combinar o orotato
de lítio com ômega-3, complexo B,
magnésio e taurina. o magnésio e taurina
vão eh potencializar o efeito do lítio.
Agora, a questão de substituir
totalmente é um pouco complicado. Talvez
que pudesse fazer eh associar os dois e
baixando a dose do carbonato e
aumentando aos poucos o rotato, tá? Mas
eu só faria isso com anuência e
acompanhamento do psiquiatra,
OK?
Vamos paraa próxima.
Qual o protocolo que pode ser utilizado
com o uso de suplementos e fitoterápicos
pro desmame gradual do Rivotrio
e ao mesmo tempo ganho de qualidade de
sono e energia para as atividades
diárias? Atualmente tenho usado 10 mg de
retalina e 300 a 400 mg de cafeína para
executar meu trabalho e fazer atividade
física.
Bem, eu geralmente para fazer desmame do
Rivoto, eu não uso fitoterápico
porque é muito difícil fazer o desmame
do rivotril. Geralmente o que que eu
faço? Eu utilizo ou extrato de cannabis,
que não é vendido como fitoterápico,
apesar de ser um fitoterápico, é
vendido, né, com uma certa bastante
regulamentação, né, na na venda. Ou
utilizaria o Fenboot, tá? Usar assim
coisas mais fracas do que isso dá para
fazer, mas é difícil, tá? Bem difícil,
porque a maioria das pessoas tá bem
viciada no Rivotril.
Ah, bem, falando de literatura, você
pode fazer uma redução de 25% do
Rivotril a cada duas semanas, se você
tiver utilizando doses moderadas a altas
ou até 50% de redução semanal, se a
pessoa tiver tomando doses mais baixas.
E aí então vai durar aí em torno de
quatro a 8 semanas esse desmame.
E assim, se você quiser tentar, eu não
tentaria sem acompanhamento médico. Eh,
eu usaria fenbot ou extrato de cannabis,
mas existe possibilidade de fazer também
esse desmame utilizando magnésio,
melatonina, ele temanina,
tá? Mas é difícil, tá? Vai depender
muito do tempo também de vício ao ao
rivotrilo, né? Quanto ao café, você vai
reduzindo progressivamente os 300 a 400
mg de cafeína,
tá? Isso para vocês se livrando da
cafeína.
Então, primeiro você desmama da cafeína
para depois pensar em talvez tirar
ritalina, certo?
[Música]
Então, para energia de urna sem cafeína
durante o desmame, você pode utilizar
rodiola rosa 300 a 500 mg por dia ou
ginzengue, né? Siberiano também é uma
boa opção. São ambos adaptógenos que
melhoram o desempenho sem estimular
demais o sistema nervoso.
Pode usar com enzima que é 10, 200, 300
mg por dia e o complexo B junto, OK?
Mas não faz tudo ao mesmo tempo, não.
Primeiro desmama o ripotril, depois
desmama a cafeína e depois você vai
reduzindo a ritalina, tá? Tem que ter
muito cuidado. Isso aí, tem que ter
muita paciência,
OK?
e o ansiolítico natural, seja o fenibut,
seja o extrato de cannabis, seja essa
combinação que eu falei deiteanina
com magnésio mais melatonina,
aí você vai usar antes do do OK?
Deixar isso aqui. Pronto.
Dr. Alão, o senhor tem experiência com o
protocolo Coimbra? Ele se aplica em
crianças com síndrome de Down. Hum,
complicado, tá? O senhor indica algum
tratamento específico?
O filho da minha amiga tem trissomido 21
livre.
Obrigada.
Complicado isso aí, né? Olha, o
protocolo cúmbia foi desenvolvido para
doença autoimune, tá? não para as
doenças
eh neurológicas ou para problema
congênito. OK?
Agora, acima de down, ele não é uma
autoimune, né? É uma condição genética
cromossômica
de nascência.
Sim, existe a situação do os portadores
de down terem componentes inflamatórios,
eu não utilizaria esse protocolo Coimbra
para isso, tá?
H, pode ser que ajude vitamina D, nesse
caso, pode ajudar, mas não o protocolo
de altas doses pensando que a de seria
uma doença autoimune. Nesse caso, não,
tá?
Hã,
mas a vitamina D poderia ajudar, mas não
pensando numa cura, OK?
Eh, eu focaria aí na otimização
nutricional, otimização da função
intestinal do microbioma.
Aí não, aí não usaria a vitamina D em
megados, usaria a suplementação
fisiológica da vitamina D, retiraria os
alimentos inflamatórios,
tá? Faria todos os tratamentos
necessários aí de fisioterapia.
Eh,
tá, mas não é que a vitamina D seria a
melhor
eh situação para isso aí.
Doutor, mais uma vez parabéns pelo
trabalho extraordinário. Obrigado. Estou
fazendo suplementação de achaganda já
por 100 dias. Estou gostando muito dos
resultados, principalmente para a
questão de energia e estresse do dia a
dia. A minha pergunta é se essa
suplementação podemos fazer uso contínuo
ou uso em longa duração pode causar
efeito. Então a ganda, como você tá
usando por conta própria, eh a
recomendação que você vai ler em
qualquer site é que é para você usar
durante 90 dias e parar, tá?
E se você tivesse com acompanhamento
médico,
aí você poderia continuar, tá? Mas
usando sozinho, a recomendação é você
parar
eh depois de 3 meses de uso,
deixa mais 3 meses de descanso e volta a
tomar mais 3 meses.
Infelizmente a gente não consegue
recomendar uso contínuo para quem não tá
fazendo acompanhamento, porque a gente
não tem dados confiáveis
na literatura para quem tá usando por
conta.
Existe alguns relatos espaços isolados
de danos hepáticos para quem utiliza por
peritos superiores a 12 semanas. OK?
Ah, como você atingiu 100 dias, que vai
dar pouco mais de 90 dias, né? Aí você
dá uma descansada, tá? Fica fica uns
meses sem tomar. Ou pode até ficar, em
vez de ficar três meses sem tomar, você
pode fazer assim, 90 dias, sim, 30 dias
não, tá?
Seria uma uma estratégia interessante.
Existe também a chance de tolerância,
né? Se você ficar tomando sem parar,
você pode desenvolver uma tolerância e o
reduzir o efeito, né, da planta. Tá bom?
E tem que tá monitorando com exames. Por
isso que eu tô falando para não fazer
isso sozinho.
Eu já fiz essa pergunta, porém acho que
não fui respondida. Meu filho tem 41
anos, saudável, aparentemente queixa-se
de mixão frequente mais que o normal.
passa bastante tempo sentado. Ele é
motorista aplicativo. Não responde isso
sim. Eu lembro dessa pergunta. Você não
deve ter visto o vídeo gravado. Você
perdeu a pergunta. Teria alguma opinião
sobre essa situação e sugestão para
tratamento?
Ã, pode ser várias razões, tá? Ele fica
muito tempo sentado
no carro, né? Porque ele dirige, né, o
carro de aplicativo.
Pode ser uma coisa psicológica por causa
do trânsito, né? Bichativo é muito comum
em pessoas que estão estressadas por
algum motivo. Então, pode ser isso. Pode
ser uma inflamação na próstata, pode ser
uma inflamação na bexiga, pode ser
infecção urinária, pode ser diabetes que
não descobriu ainda, diabetes
subclínico.
Então, é complicado, tá? Tem muitas
possibilidades. Aí eu tinha comentado
quando você perguntou da outra vez que
ficar sentado muitas horas comia a
região pélvica pode piorar a circulação
e favorecer a inflamação.
Faça ele procurar um urologista para ser
submetido a uma avaliação completa
urológica, ultrassom, psa, exame de
urina, glicemia de jejum, binaaglicada,
tirar os alimentos inflamatórios poderia
ajudar tirar os processados refinados,
reduzir a cafeína que aumenta a produção
de urina, não sei se ele bebe, bebida
alcoólica, se for o caso também reduzir,
né?
Eh, estabelecer intervalos regulares
para sair do carro e se movimentar.
Sedentarismo deve ser um problema para
ele.
Pode pensar em usar extratos também de
abóbora, salmeto, selênio, zinco. Tá
bom? Mas isso só com exames e
acompanhamento profissional.
Deixa eu ver quem fez. Ana Sena. Ana
Cena, você está ao vivo, Ana Cena,
porque senão você vai fazer essa
pergunta de novo semana que vem e vai
dizer que eu não respondi.
Gente, por favor, faça uma gentileza
para mim. Alguém escreve lá no no
WhatsApp paraa Ana Sena
e avisa ela que porque eu acho que o
pessoal não tá entendendo que as lives
ficam gravadas
e aí o pessoal acaba fazendo a novamente
a pergunta porque não acompanhou ao
vivo,
tá? Deixa eu ver se eu acho Ana Cena
aqui.
Vamos lá.
@
ver se aparece aqui. Apareceu. Pronto,
respondi a sua dúvida
hoje, mas já tinha respondido em live
anterior.
OK. Aqui se lembre, lembrem-se, né?
Colocando um plural aqui. Lembrem-se que
as lives ficam
sempre gravadas e disponíveis
para quem são disponíveis
para os membros ativos no YouTube.
Pronto.
Vamos colocar isso aqui
fixado. Certo.
Vamos fixar também. Não sei se adianta
fixar porque
o pessoal não tá vendo fixado, né?
Pronto,
vamos pra próxima.
Boa noite, Dr. Alan. O pré-treino pode
irritar o intestino mesmo sem cafeína?
Digo porque tem um problema intestinal.
Agradeço ao senhor.
Depende do que tem no pré-treino, tá?
Existe ingredientes que podem ser
problemáticos para algumas pessoas
sensíveis.
Vamos falar, por exemplo, da creatina,
que não é bem um pré-treino,
mas que tem muita gente que usa no
pré-treino, né? Tá num stack de
pré-treino. A creatina pode causar
constipação, gases em pessoas sensíveis.
Betalanina também pode causar
desconforto. Carboidratos, dependendo do
carboidrato, pode gerar desconforto.
Então, na verdade, o ideal seria você
tomar só cada elemento isoladamente para
você testar. Então, tomar creatina
isolada, tomar betalanina isolada,
tá? para você não ter problemas e depois
não saber o que que tá dando.
Mantém uma hidratação adequada
do L, 2,5 L por dia.
OK? Então seria isso aí, você tomar as
coisas isoladamente para testar.
OK? E também não sei se você tem
intestino irritável, alguma coisa assim,
seria interessante você fazer essa
avaliação.
Doutor, é verdade se deixar os vegetais
na água com bicarbonato, depois no
vinagre, tira parte dos agrotóxicos?
Parte sim, tá? Eh, os pesticidas que
estão na folha, que estão
superficialmente no caule.
Eh, tem estudos que mostram uma solução
de uma colher de sopa de bicarbonato e 1
L de água, tá? Por 12 a 15 minutos pode
remover entre 57
a 90% de certos pesticidas. Não são
todos, tá?
Esses que estão nas cascas, né, dos do
frutas, das verduras.
Como é que o bicarbonato age? Ele vai
quebrar as ligações químicas dos
pesticidas de contato, vai dissolver as
ceras naturais da casca,
mas ele não vai resolver o problema do
agrotóxico que tá lá dentro da planta,
tá?
Agora, não teria necessidade desse uso
sequencial de bicarbonato e vinagre.
Eh, a literatura pode recomendar
bicarbonato ou vinagre ou água
sanitária, mas não fala em usar
consecutivamente, não.
Só que de novo, nenhuma dessas técnicas
vai remover 100% dos agrotóxicos,
nem penetra profundamente no alimento,
vai só atuar na superfície, então ajuda,
mas não resolve 100%, tá?
E, por exemplo, o bicarbonato não vai
remover o glifosato, tá internalizado na
planta e também não vai remover metais
pesados e outros contaminantes.
Então, tente priorizar os alimentos
orgânicos, OK?
Minha irmã tem esteatose, fez
colistectomia,
no último exame deu B12 de 118. tá boa,
não tá exagerada, como algumas pessoas
pensam, eh, sem suplementar. Aí tem que
ver, é, vocês estão pensando em câncer,
provavelmente, né? Se a 19.9 de 71,
referência menor que 37, pode ser da
esteatose ou é câncer de pâncreas?
Nunca faça diagnóstico de câncer com
esses marcadores. Eles não foram feitos
para isso. Eles foram feitos para
acompanhamento pós tratamento de câncer,
tá?
Hã, tem que investigar, né? Tem que
fazer uma ressonância,
uma colang ressonância que pegue
pâncreas também ou fazer um tração
endoscópico
eh para realmente descartar
algum processo no pâncreas ou nas vias
biliares.
Ã, não é
certeza porque o B12 tá alto que seja
câncer, tá? Tem uma ligação aí, mas não
é.
Existe pessoas que t P12 elevada eh
relacionado à retirada vesícula, tá?
Então tem que fazer essa investigação
aí, OK? Verificar se tem algum problema,
fazer uma colango ressonância ou uma
ressonância com marcador MRCP.
ou um traçom endoscópico.
Doutor, sou de Portugal, estou com
triglicerídios altos e o colesterol
total também. Minha polipoproteína 1
138, a polipoproteína B 151.
Isso significa que está oxidado.
O que eu posso fazer para não ter que
tomar estatinas? Vamos fazer as contas
aqui.
É entre o apol e o apo A. O apo A tá
138, apo B
vai dar um tá? Tá de alto risco.
Então, pelo fato do dessa relação tá
1.09
é de alto risco,
existe uma chance boa do Sim do LDL tá
oxidado, tá? Então, o que que eu posso
fazer para não tomar estatinas? Nesse
caso, eu até daria estatina em dose
baixa, associaria a berberina de alta
absorção e associaria ao extrato Bgamoto
Bavite.
Então existe um exame de teste de LDL
oxidado. Para você que tá em Portugal,
você pode estar acionando
uma empresa que se chama
Nordic Labs, tá? E eles fazem essa
coleta do LDL oxidado.
Então existe sim uma chance de você tá
comidé oxidado porque porque você tem
essa relação ruim. Você deve ter
partículas pequenas e densas de LDL que
são propensas à oxidação, mas o ideal
seria testar o LDL oxidado através do
Nordic Labs.
Agora, se você não quer tomar nem dose
baixo de estatina, eu tenho um protocolo
que uso o rosto vastatina 5 mg com
bergavite, o extrato de bergamota, né,
200 mg, mas o bioberon, que é a beberina
de alta absorção, de 200.
Aí você pode estar utilizando os três
pilares, né? Eliminar os alimentos
processados, açúcares, óleos vegetais
inflamatórios como óleo de soja, milho,
canola, girassol, cortar glúten,
caseína,
aumentar antioxidantes, né? Tocotrenoid,
vitamina C, coima Q10, ômega-3,
polifenois
e melhorar o estilo de vida com sono
adequado, exercício moderado,
respiração, meditação,
tá? Seria basicamente isso.
Você tá ao vivo, Caridade.
Deixa eu ver se tem alguém aqui.
Caridade ao vivo. Blá.
Não, aparentemente não tá ao vivo não.
Pelo menos eu não tô vendo o nome dela
aqui,
mas eu só consigo ver também se fez
algum tipo de comentário ao vivo.
Bem, vamos continuar. aqui. Boa noite.
Minha pressão costuma ser mais alto que
o normal, porém não há diagnóstico de
hipertensão. Começaria a usar cápsulas
de alho da Nal Foods, onde no rótulo
informam concentrado de óleo de alho.
Alhoativum
bubo 3 mg, equivalente a 1500 mg de alho
inteiro por cápsula. Qual dosagem seria
indicada para começar? pode usar
continuamente.
Hum, será que tá certo essas informações
aí que você tá colocando? 3 mg só de
concentrado de óleo?
Porque assim, a literatura diz que o
recomendado entre 600 a 900 mg do óleo
de alho para ter um bom efeito
cardiovascular ou então utilizar o alho
envelhecido, né, o kayo
o alho negro envelhecido,
cai.
Então não tem como atingir doses
adequadas. A não ser que você tenha
colocado a dose errada aí em miligramas,
né? Não sei. Será que eu consigo achar
n? Deixa eu olhar aqui na internet.
Alho cápsulas de alho no foods. Vamos
ver aqui.
Enchinho só. Abrir outra outra janela
aqui.
Cápsulas de
para ver se você não errou a dose.
Não, aqui tá aparecendo para mim que
cada
ã cápsula tem 1500 mg, tá? Não é? Acho
que você deve ter errado aí.
Não sei, eu achei estranho mesmo.
Óleo diário e 1500 mg da Nalfoods.
Ou será? É,
deixa eu olhar aqui o rótulo dele.
É porque tá falando que é cápsula de
óleo de alho, tá? Não é que é 1500 mg de
alho que corresponde a 3 mg de do óleo.
Quer dizendo que é 1500 mg do próprio
óleo de alho. É o que tô achando aqui,
tá bom? Então, eh, nesse caso
aí você teria que tá tomando para
atingir, é, aí daria direitinho, né?
Entre 600 mg de eh de óleo e de alho por
dia, tá? Então, dá uma olhada nisso, tá?
Então, daria para você ficar só com uma
dose diária aí tranquilamente.
Doutor Alan, a suplementação de taurina
é contraindicada para quem tem pressão
baixa?
Depende, porque a taurina tem
propriedades vasodilataduras, pode
baixar pressão, mas geralmente baixa a
pressão de quem já tem pressão alta.
Ele, ela geralmente não baixa a pressão
de quem tem pressão normal ou baixa,
tem que testar, tá?
Na verdade, teria que tá tomando uma
dose mais baixa e ver como é que você
responde. Se tiver queda de pressão, aí
não pode tomar.
De preferência faça isso com
acompanhamento médico.
Disse que glúten parcialmente digerido,
que o restante é eliminado nas feeses,
em pessoas não sensíveis. Não sensíveis,
tá?
Nas pessoas sensíveis, a cativação do
imunológico e a consequente inflamação
do intestino, correto?
Então o gluto não é nunca totalmente
digerido porque ele é uma cola, tá?
Mesmo que não tem nenhum problema
teórico com glúten, não é totalmente
digerido, tá?
Ah, então a questão de digestão ou não
vai ser igual para quem é sensível e
para quem não é sensível. A diferença é
que para quem é mais sensível, ele vai
ativar muito mais o sistema imune do que
para quem não é sensível. Agora existe
provas. Dr. Fazano provou que mesmo em
pessoas que não tm nenhuma sensibilidade
ao glúten, tem hiperpermibilidade
aumentada
por conta dele.
Então, indivíduos sensíveis do glúten
estimula a produção de zonulina, aumenta
a permeabilidade intestinal mais do que
a pessoa que não é sensível. Mas todo
mundo que ingere glúten tem algum tipo
de abertura da barreira.
Tem muita gente que tem problema com
glúten e não tem sintoma intestinal, tá?
mesmo os que têm tolerância não celíaca,
vários deles vão ter xaqueca, vão ter,
por exemplo,
problemas aí de refluxo ou vão ter
problema de pele e não vão sentir nada
no intestino.
Então fique, tome cuidado com isso.
O suplemento fixa cal contém 625 mg de
carbonato de cálcio mais de 200 unidades
de vitamina D. Uma mulher idosa com
osteopenia pode usar quantos comprimidos
por dia?
Hum. A questão aí que tem muito mais
cálcio do que vitamina D, né?
A recomendação para mulheres idosas é
entre 100 e 1500 mg de cálcio alimentar
por dia. Elementar, tá? Se cada
comprimido desse fixa cálc
mg de carbonato e cálcio, seriam
necessários de dois a três comprimidos
ao dia para atingir a faixa,
considerando que a pessoa não come nada
de cálcio na dieta.
E o problema é que coloca uma quantidade
muito pequena aí de vitamina D. Então,
se você tomar dois a três comprimidos,
vai dar no máximo 600 unidades de
vitamina D por dia.
E aí tem que tá complementando com mais
um comprimido de pelo menos 2.000
unidades separadas aí,
OK? Então, teria que complementar esse
suplemento com a vitamina D extra. Dois
a três comprimidos desse fixa cal mais
2000 a 4000 unidades de vitamina D
separado aí.
Certo?
Boa noite, Dra. Alan. Qual a sua opinião
de litotâ? Nunca estudei esse
litotânium. Tá,
como você pediu para dar opinião, o que
eu pude apurar sobre isso, eu nunca
utilizei, é que é uma alga rica em
cálcio, magnésio,
tem bastante aminoácido, como é o caso
das algas em geral, tem vários
óleoemens, como zinco, bora e manganês.
Eu
preciso até fazer pensar em fazer uma um
vídeo sobre isso, tá? É um é uma coisa
que era meio nova para mim, tá? Mas de
modo geral eu recomendo sim, pelo que eu
pouco que eu li a respeito.
Gente, eu vou pedir para vocês só um
minutinho, eu vou ao banheiro bem
rapidinho, eu já volto, tá bom?
Muito bem. Deixa eu antes de eu
continuar ver a interação ao vivo de
vocês aqui.
Sor Ana Paula convidando a todos para
uma live de domingo às 11 horas da
manhã. Esse horário foi ela que
escolheu, tá gente? Não fui eu, porque
ela mora em Portugal sobre o desafio da
Cetosa, tá? Essa live vai ser aberta.
Já falamos do SIS,
ela deixando claro que a feira de saúde
vai tá aberta para o público em geral.
Vai ser gratuito esse acesso aí.
Trona Paula fazendo observação sobre o
EPA na depressão bipolar, como eu falei,
ela tá sugerindo uso do Icosa da
Biobalance.
Se precisarem tem na loja cirúrgica
bergamota
e Cosacor Biobalance.
Dosar cortisol em curva salivar,
monitorar a parte glicêmica.
Pessoas com hipoglicemia têm sintomas de
pânico. Ela tá falando aqui do desmame
do Rivotril.
Dieta com muito caro e pouco exercício,
pior os sintomas mentais. Totalmente
verdade.
Aqui ela tá complementando aquela
resposta que eu falei sobre o uso da
rodola,
né, para energia.
S de DAL. Muitas vezes tem questões de
cardiopatia e também problemas de
articulações.
Ah,
colocar fixado o grupo de apoiadores. A
live de domingo da Cetose.
O card do CIS colocar fixado.
Dá para fixar foto? Não sei. Vou ver lá
depois.
Não sei se dá para fazer isso não.
OK. Vamos tentar depois.
pessoal do grupo nível dois, né, de
estudos avançados,
tá tendo uma questão aí que não tão
comparecendo ao vivo.
Eu acho uma boa usar o aparelho zonizado
para limpeza de alimentos, mas não
contando que vai tirar todos os
agrotóxicos.
As perguntas eh são feitas num documento
que a gente compartilha, tá? A gente
compartilha no WhatsApp, deixa fixado no
WhatsApp o formulário.
Doutor não tá trocando as perguntas no
YouTube, só no Streamyard. Como é que é?
Não entendi nada.
Que que você quis dizer com isso aqui?
Doutor, não tá trocando as perguntas no
YouTube só no Streamyard? Não. Tá, tá
trocando o YouTube, sim. É porque tem um
delay. Eu acho que você não tá
entendendo que tem um delayzinho.
Ah,
gostaria de saber se usa o ácido folino
e cometolato quando necessário. Uso a
quando uso um e outro. O ácido folínico
eu só uso na prática para autismo e para
pacientes com câncer que estão tomando
quimioterapia que
depleta o ácido fólico. Tá,
tá aqui o tor na Paula dando suas
observações.
Mais informações. Dra. Ana Paula.
Gente, se cair a live é por causa que tá
chovendo e deu um
relâmpago aqui, tá? Porque a gente mora
na
no Banglad, né? Quando chove cai energia
toda vez. Impressionante.
Bem, vamos continuar as perguntas aqui.
Deixa eu voltar mostrar minha tela aqui.
Eita, não, não é isso não. Edit state.
Pronto.
Pronto. Vamos voltar aqui.
Doutor, poderia dar uma dica sobre
peptídeos onde devemos estudar? Boa
pergunta. Existem trabalhos científicos
confiáveis?
Bem, a gente tem publicações recentes em
revistas de altíssimo impacto. A Nature
Reviews Chemistry
mostrou artigos sobre peptídios.
É muito interessante esse artigo, é
porque ele mostrou que sintetizar
peptídeos em massa para por design
estrutural
está sendo
substituído por inteligência artificial
e modelagem computacional. Muito
interessante isso.
Então, de Botucatu tem pesquisadores
estudando isso.
Tem algumas aplicações clínicas
aprovadas pela Anvisa,
porém tem muitos perptidos por aí sendo
vendidos como milagrosos, mas é hype e
são promessas enfundadas.
Desconfie muito de promessas milagrosas
em redes sociais, tá? Mas acompanhe
porque essa tecnologia está para ficar
está evoluindo.
Tomar cuidado só com os milagreiros.
Eh, eu vou ver se eu faço uma live, se
me deu uma ideia boa. Vou fazer o
seguinte. A próxima live que eu vou
fazer sobre
estudos avançados, tá? De domingo que a
gente faz a cada duas semanas, eu vou
fazer especificamente sobre isso, tá? Eu
vou fazer uma live super completa sobre
peptídeos, o que confiar e o que não
confiar, tá? Então vai ser sem sexto
domingo, no outro domingo. Vou fazer uma
live sobre isso. Você me deu uma ideia
muito boa, Eduardo. Obrigado.
Boa noite, quadro Osagens do Audiesta
Tra Chantina. como suplemento vai
depender, tá? Geralmente entre 4 a 8 mg
por dia.
Tem gente que toma 12, mas seria entre 4
a 8 mg.
Quando você tem uma inflamação grande,
uma artrite, uma tendinite, você poderia
estar utilizando essas doses mais altas.
É bem seguro. Eu falei isso na live, não
foi nem live, foi um vídeo, né, que eu
gravei. É muito seguro para uso
contínuo.
Não tem problema nenhum.
Não tem problema. Como é o caso do
adaptógeno, você tem que fazer aquela
parada que não expliquei.
Então fique tranquilo. Você pode até
começar com uma dose mais alta no
começo, depois baixar para 4 a 6 mg.
E eu tô tomando agora, eu coloquei esta
chanchantina dentro do meu stack de
suplementos.
Dr. Vander Ribeiro Pires e também Dr.
Renato Eslonca, ambos do protocolo
Coimbra, há anos postam centenas de
depoimentos pacientes com seus canais
Instagram e YouTube. Tem depoimento de
tudo quanto é doença autoimune. É
verdade que é proibido por lei médico
fazer isso?
Não é lei, na verdade é uma
regulamentação, é uma resolução do CFM
que eu não concordo.
E essa norma foi atualizada em 2023.
Essa norma permite que você
reposte em redes sociais. Isso foi uma
mudança, né? Porque antigamente não
podia. Então, com essa mudança, eles
estão deixando repostar elogios e
depoimento de pacientes.
Só que tem alguns requisitos.
tem que ter autorização expressa por
escrito, né, dessa pessoa que tá
divulgando o elogio.
Os os depoimentos teoricamente teriam
que ser sóbrios, né? Isso nas palavras
do Conselho de Medicina, né? Vai saber o
que que eles acham que que é sóbrio. Não
poderia então ter adjetivos que denotem
superioridade ou promessa de resultado.
Também é altamente subjetivo isso e não
pode repostar de maneiras contínuas.
O ponto crítico é aqui que o conselho
pode interpretar, se você tá tendo
centenas de depoimentos postados de
maneira repetida, isso poderia, na visão
deles, caracterizar a repostagem
reiterada,
tá? E isso daí geralmente tá problema.
né? Por exemplo, eu me lembro que há uns
dois ou três anos atrás o conselho
mandou tirar do ar
que era de depoimentos, né, de pacientes
que estavam fazendo o protocolo Coimbra
e deixaram o CRM do Dr. Coimbra
eh temporariamente cancelado.
E foi um bafafá na época que eles
estavam entendendo que o site era do
Coimbra e o, no caso, a página do
Facebook era do Coimbra e não era, era
da de uma galera lá que não tinha nada a
ver com o Coimbra.
Então tem a tal do Comissão de
Divulgação de Assuntos Médicos, que é o
Codame, é o órgão regulatório aí da
publicidade médica.
Eles investigam quando tem elogios
sistemáticos e reiterados, tá? Eles
entendem isso como publicidade médica
irregular,
especialmente em páginas com grande
número de seguidores.
Então, na verdade, é muito subjetivo
isso daí, tá? É só os caras quererem que
eles enchem o saco e acabou.
O segredo seria ter o consumimento
informado de cada um desses depoimentos.
Você
se importa em pesquisar se o suplemento
glicina prolonga a duração do do sono
rein? Eu já falei isso em vídeo, eh, não
falei exatamente nesses termos, mas eu
falei num vídeo sobre glicina pro sono.
E sim, ela prolonga a duração do sono
rin.
Quando você toma glicina antidorim, você
atinge o sono profundo mais rapidamente
e também aumenta a quantidade de sono
rein durante a noite.
Eu tenho recomendado uns meses para cá
glicina 3 g antes de dormir.
Ah, muitas vezes eu sócio o magnésio e
às vezes a pigenina para melhorar o
sono.
Belê. Eu falei isso num vídeo, tá
gravado no YouTube lá, só dar uma
olhada. Boa noite, Dr. Alan. Quanto
antioxidantes, qual melhor, vitamina E
ou as tachantina? Seria o tocotrienois,
tá? Que não é não é qualquer vitamina E.
São oito vitâminos da vitamina E. Os
melhores são os tocotrienois, gama e
delta. São os melhores antioxidantes.
Ou se seria a taxantina, eles seriam
mais é complementares, tá?
Os tocotrienoidis vão proteger a
membrana celular contra os danos
oxidativos e a taxantina é um
carotenoide
muito potente, só que não consegue agir
simultaneamente em diferentes camadas
das membranas, né? E já o tocotrenol,
ele atravessa facilmente a membrana.
H, então estudos comparando o alfa,
tocoferol, não todos os tipos de
vitamina E mostram que a tachantina é 50
vezes mais potente que a vitamina E
normal, OK?
Só que a taxina sozinha não vai
conseguir penetrar todas as camadas.
Então, seria interessante associar os
dois, né? Como eu já falei aqui, entre 4
a 8 mg de asta com 100 mg de
tocotrenoise ao dia.
Se você tiver com uma doença mais grave,
você pode aumentar até 400 mg de
tocotrenois ao dia, mas eu começarei com
100 mg,
tá bom? Lembrando que a vitamina E esta
chanchantinas são liposolúveis, então
utilizar ela junto com alguma gordura
saudável como ômega3 ou óleo de coco.
Essa foi a última, acho que foi foi a
última pergunta. Deixa eu ver que vocês
estão falando ao vivo aqui.
A que horas é a live?
É agora. Ah, não. Você tá perguntando da
da live do
do dos apoiadores, é isso? Aliás, do
nível dois. Vai ser domingo, 7 horas da
noite, mas não vai ser esse domingo
agora. Esse domingo agora nós vamos
fazer a live com a nutricionista Andreia
Torre sobre
a experiência que nós tivemos de
monitorar a cetose durante as duas
semanas.
H Pet Strong da Essential foi proibido a
venda.
Não é, não é o Pept Strong, Estela
Mares. Acho que é o Pept Strong você tá
falando, né?
Eu com esse produto eu não sabia não. Eu
que foi proibido pela Anvisa, não. Eh,
serviço onde?
Ah, tá. Você deve est falando dos
peptídios, né? Não, mas o peptídeos que
nós estamos falando é outros, tá? Não é
aquele peptídio que toma viorol, não é
peptídio usado endovenoso.
Você tá falando de peptídeos eh a no
sentido de ser aminoácidos essenciais,
né?
Bem, eu não tô mais sabendo disso. Vou
eu vou dar uma olhada, viu? Se Mas eu
acho que você tá falando do Pept Strong.
Você colocou Pet Strong, mas eu acho que
isso aqui dizer PT strong.
Ã, no site da Anvisa, tá? Eu vou dar uma
olhada depois, tá? Mas Estela é o Pept
Strong. Deixa eu escrever aqui. Você tá
falando, você escreveu errado sem
querer. Ah, deixa eu ver aqui. P pá.
Vou escrever aqui. Pept Strong. É esse
que você tá falando?
seria esse aqui
também. Gostaria de entrar no WhatsApp.
Ah, então é o seguinte, viu? Eu vou
colocar o link. Na verdade, esse link tá
lá no YouTube. Vai lá no YouTube, tá?
Onde você se inscreveu
e tem lá o link lá, tá bom? Se eu
colocar o link aqui, não posso colocar o
link aqui porque todo mundo que tá aqui
e já tá inscrito, tá? Deixa eu colocar o
link para você.
Hã, só um minuto de achar esse link
aqui.
Não, não tá aqui. Tá lá no YouTube. Pera
aí que eu vou achar e vou te passar.
É que isso tá meio escondido também.
Deixa eu achar isso aqui. Pera aí.
YouTube Studio.
Deixa eu achar aqui.
Clubes dos canais.
Benefícios da assinatura.
Pera aí, vamos achar aqui
o link. Grupo no WhatsApp. Tá aqui.
Ah, aqui. Deixa eu colocar o link.
Gente, não divulguem esse link fora
aqui, tá? Do YouTube, da área de
membros, tá? senão as pessoas que não
estão
assinando
vão conseguir entrar no grupo.
Olha o, eu não sei como é que fala o seu
nome, Ranel.
É isso, ó. Tá aqui esse o link aqui, tá
bom? para você entrar no
grupo do WhatsApp se você não tá.
Solana Paula foi pesquisar o Pept
Strong.
Anvisa determina a suspensão imediata do
Pept Strong no Brasil. Agência Nacional
de Vigilância. Anvisa suspendeu
temporariamente
todos os produtos da Essential
Nutrition. Todos.
O problema é outro. O Pept Strong é
considerado um novo ingrediente no
Brasil. Precisa passar por avaliação
específica de segurança,
ã, antes ser liberada para uso em
alimento suplemento,
tá? Não é que foi proibido no sentido de
que deu deu bo lá, mas é porque
a PvTR utilizaria uma tecnologia inédita
no Brasil.
A Essential afirma que a proteína da
Fava é segura que o Pep Trolong recebeu
em 2024 certificação GR.
O GR é
e generally recognized safe. Generally
recogniz safe.
No entanto, a avaliação norte-americana
não substitui a análise obrigatória da
Anvisa.
O formulário fica dentro do YouTube,
desculpa, do YouTube não, do do
grupo do WhatsApp, mas na verdade eu
deveria ter colocado também no YouTube.
Foi bom você ter falado isso.
Esse formulário, na verdade, foi falha
minha. Devia ter colocado também como
post,
tá? Já que você falou isso, na próxima
semana eu não vou esquecer de fazer
isso, colocar também como post dentro do
YouTube, porque as pessoas também não
são obrigadas a ficarem num grupo do
WhatsApp.
Tá bom.
Ah, entrou no grupo. Obrigada. Tá ótimo.
Que bom.
Pode ser Anne,
que que é Anne? Não sei. Não entendi
não.
B, vamos ver se eu perdi algum
comentário aqui.
B.
O aço colônico é o ideal porque
atravessa a barreira imatecefálica. Não
entendi. É folínico. Ah, tá beleza.
Sim. O ideal para pessoas com autismo,
tá?
E sim, tem um mecanismo de passagem do
ácido furínico pro cérebro que não
depende de umas enzimas lá. Por isso que
ele é, e quem tem autismo tem um
problema lá com o receptor de ácido
fólico. É por isso que é o folínico que
usa pro autismo, tá?
Hã, eu acho que é isso, né, pessoal? Já
deu uma hora de live,
sim. Toda semana o formulário é
divulgado no WhatsApp, tá? Mas eu vou
divulgar também no YouTube. Foi bom você
ter me falado isso daí.
Bem, pessoal, muito muito obrigado pela
presença de vocês. Deixa eu me colocar
de volta aqui e nós nos falamos então na
próxima semana, na próxima terça, para
responder as dúvidas e no domingo, sem
ser esse o outro, para o grupo dois de
estudos avançados.
Antes de sair, deixa eu colocar esse
comentário, Paula.
Não esqueçam a live às 11 horas domingo
sobre o desafio da cetose.
Boa noite, querida Alice Vog. Um beijo
para você e pro Mário. Tá bom. Tchau,
pessoal. Até a próxima semana.